like just a crime scene of a mouse
yeah
[Music]
hey i'm kelsey cook and i'm here to
answer the internet this is such a
thinker is jerking off to nudes of a
girl who has died weird or a nice
tribute i'm trying to think if i had
died
and i was looking down i mean i don't
want to watch a dude no the verbiage
here with it being a nice tribute i
don't know if i'd call it a nice
tribute getting come on your phone
screen on like a dead girl's face i
don't know what if you're like thinking
about like your high school girlfriend
is that but you're now older and like
technically
she was young you know what i mean like
is that allowed
this sounds like a very personal
situation
maybe we should would you rather give up
the hungover breakfast sandwich or the
drunk pizza you want to know what's sad
is that i have ibs and i can't eat bread
or cheese
this is really a hypothetical for me i
would give up
the drunk breakfast sandwich
the hungover breakfast sandwich because
drunk pizza
oh
i almost thought i had done um cocaine
in vegas once because i woke up and
there was like white powdery stuff in my
belly button and i touched it and i
tasted it and i was like oh
parmesan cheese
and i had just eaten so much drunk pizza
that i like dumped a loose quarter cup
of parm down my shirt
and then just slept on it and didn't
know so
i would i would keep the drunk pizza i
love it back the [ __ ] out of the fact
that you were down to ride that morning
oh this day is going to go one of two
different ways
if you had to move it to a different
place on the body where would you put
the vagina maybe like
low back because
in terms of sex there's a lot of like
maneuvering that always has to happen
but if it's in your back you can just be
chilling and somebody can [ __ ] you from
behind that answer is sponsored by my
chiropractor because i'm just i'm
getting older now i'm thinking of [ __ ]
that's like you know what that would
keep me in alignment and it would save
me [ __ ] money
i'm putting it in my bag
would you rather get paid one million
dollars a year but have to work
ridiculous hours
or get 1 000 sorry 100 000 a year for
doing nothing 100 000 a year for doing
nothing i know it's great for women to
be independent and i love working and
all this [ __ ] but if i could get 100k to
like sit and diddle myself all day
absolutely if you could die and come
back as any inanimate object what would
it be oh my little foosball man i was
like that is there a particular
my middle forward
that'd be a good time because i was
telling you on the podcast i'm 5'4 every
sport i've ever played i've always been
like the sutter or the person that
doesn't get any glory so to be that man
and just kick the [ __ ] out of the ball
that would be great i would love that is
there something that makes you
automatically swipe right on tinder if
they have a great smile that's like oh
that's a that's a weakness that's hard
to pass up on
if their bio makes me laugh
and isn't douchey then that's also a
great plus
i
love foosball more than anything in the
world is that you turn on or turn off
well i would have to know them i'm sure
because there's like 43 football players
but no i would love that i mean if
somebody's really good at foosball that
is a huge turn on to me okay what's like
the worst thing they could do like a lot
of jewelry if it's like too much of a
captain jack sparrow vibe if i feel like
you have more accessories than i do then
that's concerning and a bunch of near
selfies if it's all mirrors
if you could oh this is good if you
could play one video game for the rest
of your life which would it be probably
mario party
i love a good mario party or mario kart
or diddy kong racing i'm gonna attend
okay
if you could wipe one group of people
off the earth who would it be just a
quick genocide um people who don't
return their shopping carts to the
shopping cart area of the parking lot
what are the best starburst flavors pink
always pink and red what is that
strawberry and cherry what if i said
orange like a monster it goes pink
orange
yellow red be honest what that's what it
does no no it does not
would you rather every porn you watch
for the rest of your life have music or
be in a foreign language i'm fine with
foreign language i'm not concerned about
the dialogue i felt like music is really
broad that could have been anything and
if somebody had the freedom to put like
country in or like god forbid like
sesame street music or some [ __ ] like
i can't come to that so i would deal
with
foreign language
if you only had five dollars to get
drunk what would you buy and then the
picture has just bleach on it
it's happening i would do
the largest size i could have like a
sour beer or
really
ipa
something super hoppy what's like what's
the most disgusting thing you used to
get drunk on probably like 99 bananas
who are your top five porn stars
i don't think i can give five i can give
two so adriana czech
[Laughter]
[Music]
like insane with what she's willing to
do and she's so hot she is prolific
she is filthy she did a tweet one time
that has burned into my brain she said
i'm at my dentist right now and he has
no idea how many different dna strands
he's cleaning out of my teeth
and i was like
what the [ __ ] like just a crime scene of
a mouse
yeah
that mountain
yes it must have been a new dentist
because i believe she has also tweeted
or at least said our podcast
that she got her back molar shaved yeah
so she can suck bigger dick
what a commitment to the craft right
you gotta love it
she said for her i think for her
birthday every year she does like a new
scene where she like pushes the limits
and last year she found out what the
longest
the longest porn she could find so she
was like doing her own research the
longest porn she could find if someone
being triple penetrated and she did 43
straight minutes
with
all three oh my holes hurt just thinking
about that
that's like her everest is like three
so my other one i have to give a shout
out to jessie rogers who is a retired
porn star but she was so well known in
that one year she did it have you guys
heard of her
incredible ass so here's the thing the
reason i know about her is because my
friend jay told me that she's my
celebrity lookalike
so when i googled her the first picture
that popped up was her doing hardcore
anal and then
i got creeped out realizing that my
friend jay saw that and was like
you know who this reminds me of
old gaping butt hole kelso
oh back door cook look at her go that's
good
if you're watching on youtube click here
to subscribe so you get all the new
episodes as they come out and john what
should they click if they want
notifications
make sure you click thumbs up for the
like hit that bell icon